abajo con el gobierno del hambre crearon
miles de manifestantes en jartúm todos
ellos están en contra de que el consejo
soberano la junta cívico militar que
gobierna el país siga en el poder a las
afueras del palacio presidencial
la gran mayoría reclamo por un gobierno
100% militar que los saque de la aguda
crisis política y económica
el ejército es capaz puede proteger el
país y dirigirlo correctamente cuando
alguien tiene miedo se va y se esconde
pero el único lugar detrás del cual
tenemos que escondernos son las fuerzas
armadas ellos son la base de la
seguridad los manifestantes le echan la
culpa al gobierno de transición de la
inflación que alcanza un 400 por ciento
y la eliminación de los subsidios a los
alimentos básicos austeridad decretada
por el fm y para eliminar la deuda del
país a lyon tiene su cambio justo hoy en
día un kilo de azúcar vale hasta 550
libras sudanesas y el pan 100 libras la
gente tiene que hacer fila para comprar
lo quemamos malvive tomamos el primer
ministro abdalá hands ok ya debilitado
por un fallido golpe
el pasado 21 de septiembre calificó a la
crisis actual como la peor y la más
peligrosa desde que subió al poder en
2019 año en que el autócrata omar
al-bashir fue derrocado tras 30 años en
el poder militares y civiles formaron
luego un gobernante consejo soberano que
se supone llevará al país a elecciones
por el momento previstas para 2023
mientras que los manifestantes
anunciaron que no abandonaran la sede
del palacio presidencial hasta que el
gobierno sea reemplazado por militares
seguidores de la junta cívico militar
convocaron a un mitin el próximo jueves